hey everyone it's lucy here today i'm
joined by patrick who is an associate
professional services consultant at aws
he has eight aws certifications and
today we're going to be talking
primarily about the aws security
specialty certification
hey patrick how are you today not too
bad pretty good
so patrick how did you go about
preparing for this exam
do you have any tips and tricks for any
viewers out there who
are planning to sit this exam sure yeah
yeah so
i guess when it comes to the security
specialty exam or just studying for
exams in general
uh how i study for these exams is i have
this kind of
tree step agenda which comprises of the
first step being i use a tool called
a cloud guru so i think this is a this
has helped me out my
throat every aws star i've gone for
usually i use this
tool to get started on a cert so i go in
let's say i'm going for
security i do the whole course video by
video
i then sit the exam at the end and then
that
gets me started on the content now the
second part
to that is i use another tool which is
more for the the practice
side of things i use a tool called wiz
labs and wiz labs is pretty good because
they generate a lot of exams so in a
cloud group they only offer
one with wiz labs they offer a whole
different
types of questions and so between those
and and
with labs in a cloud guru i get good
practice
on the types of questions i would be
asked now the last step
which is kind of the the one percenter
to make me comfortable going into exam
is i then take those services that i'm
studying so
and let's say kms for example this is a
dominant topic
in the security exam and i would go into
the aws documentation
and then i would read through the
service line by line
now the reason i do this is because
sometimes
in the exam or in the practice exams you
might get
asked questions that are one-liners
they're
very very unique and very niche and
without really using the service in
depth it can be hard to answer
these questions so when you're reading
through the documentations
sometimes these tiny tiny details
stick out so that's all those tools
together they
they come together and that was really
what i did to
prepare for the security exam nice okay
yeah sounds like a mix of
um you know learning about the different
services
through a cloud guru database
documentation and also
through practice tests and yeah i think
that's a really good approach
so my next question is and this is
something that a lot of the viewers
always ask about how difficult is the
aws security exam
um relative to the other exams so you
know the
cloud practitioner associate solutions
architect and even the professional ones
i think specialty exams are very very
interesting compared to the other side
of things that
i i'm assuming that most of the viewers
are associate or cloud prac thinking of
going specialty
those types of questions the associate
types questions
they tend to ask general knowledge
on a lot of services now this differs to
the security specialty because
in security specialty there's only a
couple
of the top of my head might be wrong
five or six
key services in aws that
when you go into the specialty exam or
into the security exam
these are kind of what the questions are
focused around so you won't necessarily
switch between services
in associate but you would rather be
asked
deeper like very very deep questions
continually about the same question now
that ties into the the concept of
difficulty because
in the associate if you have a general
knowledge on a lot of services you can
quite easily go comfortable into that
exam and get a pretty good score
and with the specialty however you need
to really drill down
on these key services so personally i
don't think
they're hard i just think that um
especially for the security one i think
it's a great lead on if you've got all
the associates you'll actually find that
in those in the practice for those exams
you have already been preparing yourself
for security so i think it's a good
leap way or a good stepping stone if
you're thinking of going for a specialty
but it's not impossible if you learn
these services
80 to 90 as to what they can do
then you can quite easily go into this
exam comfortable and
getting a higher score so it's a deeper
but narrow scope for these exams that
makes a lot of sense so for the
associate ones you're kind of expected
to know about
so many different services but not
really in detail for all of them
but whereas you know security specialty
and the other special
certifications they'll focus on a
specific set of services
and you'll be required to know a bit
more in detail and
speaking of these services right for
security specialty which
services do you focus on the most and
which ones do you
think came up the most during your
practice exams and during the exam just
anything you felt like um students can
really focus on
when preparing for the exam so i think
now thinking off the top i'm thinking of
all the services it might relate to
the dominant and this just sticks out to
me just because
um encryption is a big deal or in terms
of security encryption is kind of like
the first angle people look at
if you really want to kick start for the
security exam
become very familiar with kms
and cloud hsn those two services if i'm
remembering from my security exam
they came up a lot another topic that
came up a lot was
not necessarily networking but the
security
of networks so looking into stuff like
knackles
security groups waff if you want to
get a good start in security i think if
you focus on
encryption so kms and cloud hsl and then
combine that with the networking side of
things so looking into vpc's
security groups that will give you a
good bulk
of the security exam and then the rest
you just naturally have to learn
about them and yeah that's what i would
say yeah
that's very helpful and for my upcoming
security exam as well
i'll keep those services in mind so
patrick my final question
is what challenges did you face when you
were studying for the security specialty
i know one thing we mentioned just
offline was a lot of the time in forums
we see that
students tend to overestimate the
difficulty of the exam
because sometimes you know you think
that you need a couple of years of
experience in a certain domain so is
that something
we should talk about as well to the
viewers so i'll take
two angles on this question so the first
angle is the
challenging part of it and now at the
start i mentioned one of the techniques
i used when i studied for exams
was that after i've done the quizzes and
hack guru
i then go take those services it doesn't
have to be all of them but just the
services that i know
go in depth like kms i take them to the
aws documentation
and then going page by page or tab by
tab
for some this doesn't work but for me it
works because
when you read these documentations they
reveal those types of
questions that might come up in the exam
but you don't necessarily learn
from watching a video you know like when
we talk about kms it might be a couple
of videos about the key features
but because it's a specialty exam there
is going to be some questions
that are going to be very very one-liner
the type of questions where
you see it once and then if you don't
really think about it for a while you
might forget about it
but i would recommend from the
challenging side like get familiar with
the questions
that aren't main features the types of
questions
that are hidden behind the main page
but are still an option now the other
side of it which you did mention with
the forums
specialty exams when for me i'm going to
speak
when i finished all my associates i was
looking at you know what was the next
exam
i could go for is it a pro or could i
take
a stab at a specialty and for a while i
was actually quite afraid
of sitting a specialty i say this
because
when i was studying the content i kept
seeing that in order to comfortably sit
this exam you should really have
two to five years of experience on this
topic so whether it's databases or data
analytics you should have
worked in this industry for a minimum of
two to five
to feel like you're ready to sit it now
for me that that scared me a lot i was
thinking
geez okay like the professionals they
recommend two years but
five years must mean these exams are
really really hard so for a while i
actually
kind of paralyzed for a bit i was in the
stage where i felt i was ready
you know i was sitting these exams and i
was getting okay scores i guess
but i was kind of thinking should i
continue and actually set the exam
or is this a conversation for a while
later
long story short my tip for that is
just do it the specialty exams yes they
are harder
they go more in depth but it's a more
narrow scope exactly
well there were so many good pieces of
advice in that answer
so yeah with that i think we've sort of
covered all the questions that we have
prepared
um but if you have any other questions
please leave them down in the comments
below and we'll get back to you
and let us know what certification video
you would like to see next
bye for now